had you already filmed the prank panel
with Knoxville
uh when you did season 666 no we wrapped
May of last year may 2022 we wrapped
season six and then prank panel we did
in the fall and winter of okay now
how do you already done the prank panel
and famously
um stressed your relationship with
Knoxville
would that have affected your shooting
with Tremaine on uh season 6660 thing no
because uh
I don't think there's anybody that's
been tortured by Knoxville more than
Jeff right Jeff was the one so I did I'm
doing the show with Knoxville
and I know he's gonna prank me
and he's like the liquid Terminator he's
hard to prank back because he feels no
pain
and then if you do bring him back and he
gets pissed it's like you've unleashed
the [__] monster yeah it's a
lose-lose so he keeps like hitting me
with tasers and stuff like that oh my
gosh off the bat
so day three and then like I quit like
the like three days into shooting
because I was like it's only gonna get
worse I don't want to do I was like
I was like it's a nice gig but I it's
not worth the stress I have other gigs
to to keep me afloat
so I called Jeff and I was like and then
I said I quit out of nerves the first
few days
and then Knoxville tucked me back into
it but also Jeff I go Jeff what do I
what do I do like
it's a lose-lose if I
if I hit Knoxville with a prank he's
gonna hit back tenfold and Jeff just
goes yeah you got it you gotta hit him
back because he's gonna keep he's gonna
keep killing you you gotta tase him or
do something like I don't know if it was
the best advice so I have like a I have
a stun gun next to my bed
and I had a long sleeve shirt on and
pants at work so I go to set in
Knoxville it's like a Show's like
American Idol or shark tank but for
pranks so people come on and they pitch
pranks to to try to convince us to help
them produce it because they want to
prank their cousin or their wife or
their husband whatever
so we're interviewing a contest and a
potential contestant
and uh Knoxville's like asking her
questions and I like slowly take this
long it looks like a police
yeah take this long thing awkwardly out
of my clothes and I just try to like
nail them right in the chest with it I
was like I gotta make it count because
yeah you know it's gonna be a day so I
like nail him but the guy is like
James Bondville and he was just getting
electrocuted and then he just like
grabbed it out of my hand and then he
had another weapon in his pocket already
and he started nailing me with both
things and I run and he's got me on the
ground he's just like nailing me with
both um stun guns and this lady is just
standing there like what the [__] he
chased me out of the studio
and then uh
I was like I'm in a world to her no
that's when I first quit I was like I'm
in a world of hell I was like this is
gonna be and Knoxville's smiling ear to
ear because he's like oh that's great we
got footage this is great that lady was
boring and we made we made and it is
great and I totally understand the value
I was not like wait why would he want to
continue this type of debauchery I
totally yeah I'm a super fan of Jackass
so like I totally get it it's only wrong
if it doesn't happen on camera
yes yeah yeah there you go
and uh
so I don't remember the next day oh I
had the props Department rig a little
water gun right by his crotch and
because we sit at this big desk yeah and
I had them cue the water again while
he's interviewing another contestant
it's nailing him in the crotch so when
he looks I wanted him to stand up and it
looked would look like he peed his pants
but he didn't really react he was just
like and he was like go ahead and I
could see him getting like angry I was
like oh [__] like cartoon thermometer
like Elmer Fudd frustrated and I was
like [__] and then I turned to look at
the producers and he stun gunned me in
the neck and it was like the most
unbelievable pain I mean you guys have a
high pain tolerance and not really
really I don't think we do
right but but
just that our desire for attention
outweighs our desire for comfort
but this is like Unbelievable pain that
like went into my brain and it you're
just you can't not be in a bad mood so
then I quit then I quit and I was like I
have to quit permanently
and then uh
he called me the next day to apologize
and
I was like uh look I totally get it I
grew up on jackass you guys jackass came
out when at the perfect time for he came
out when I was in 12th grade and it was
the perfect and I remember I had the CKY
tapes and everything it was a perfect
show to grow like be like in those
formative years experiencing and I was
like I love you I love what you do I
completely am not taking it personally I
completely understand the comedic value
but it's just me and Gabourey Sidibe I
know you ain't gonna [__] stun gun or
tase Gabby Sidibe
so you're just gonna attack me and I was
like I can't be your pinkish I can't be
your punching bag for every day day in
and day out every episode every season
at least like jacked ass like he spreads
the wealth a little bit there's like
nine of you there's a whole Wu-Tang Clan
of you that he can punish right at any
time so and you're all in it together
and there's like it's kind of like
there's like he's spreading the wealth a
little bit he's not just picking on you
or picking on Zach or picking on you
it's a little bit more like you're just
saying I can't be a danger Aaron
no hard feelings I was like I can't come
back I was ignored feeling you can
replace me with Aaron I think I
suggesting I was like you can replace me
with Aaron you can like what no hard
feelings I just can't be in that
position I just don't like the stress is
not worth the gig or the money or
anything I'd rather have my mental
health and work on other projects where
I'm not giving a time so he goes I'll do
it I've never done before I'll call the
truce I won't prank you anymore I was
like it's not pranks it's just like
assault with a weapon
synonymous for now yeah
exactly I was like I it's not worth the
stress so then we called it truce and I
could tell and I was like as sure if you
want to do that if you want me back on I
was like I don't want you to hold a
grudge or any animosity because I'm
taking your toys away I want you to have
your superpowers I just can't be the one
that you Unleash Your superpowers on and
he's like I hold no grudge no animosity
it's all peace and love so and I never
took it personally I totally got that it
was part of it I was like it's your
stick I understand shtick you got you
got a thing and you right you figured it
out and you you cracked the system the
comedy entertainment system in your own
way and I just can't be Aaron yeah I
can't be Aaron he was able to so I came
back and we just didn't prank each other
all right he was able to get honor his
word
yeah I mean there was a couple of
[__] objects thrown at my crotch or
something like that but no like stun gun
no weapons to the neck kind of thing
right and I even told him at the end I
was like you can fire me between Caesar
I can tell your your powers are on the
Shelf I don't want to like I I still am
like kind of apologizing I'm like I'm so
sorry you can't attack me anymore it's
very like I'm like I have Stockholm
Syndrome
getting tased in the neck and then
apologizing to the person that tastes
you I'm so sorry that because I
understand what it's like to be
um creatively in like stifled you know
so I don't want to ever and I told him
that too I was like I don't want to uh
neuter your creative choices I just
don't want to be attacked I was like
you're kind of like Ike Turner right now
like talking Tina Turner back on the
stage like come on baby I'm sorry I
punched you in the face come on back and
sing
and and do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is Stevo's butt wipes
for your butt hole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude